all right welcome everybody
we are back once again and we
are waiting to see if indeed
the count will continue if you were with
us
earlier what was meant to be a
perfunctory and merely ceremonial
counting of the ballot's electoral
ballots was
interrupted as essentially
violent insurrectionist trumpists
stormed the capitol
and mike pence was escorted out to
safety by secret service
members of house and senate leadership
as well as members of the house and
senate
everything imploding because of these
uh violent trumpists and we are now
seeing
a curfew descend over washington dc
and slowly slowly slowly
um normality to some degree will be
returning to
the capitol as you can see people sort
of more walking away than towards
and we are seeing police as well as it
appears
state troopers from virginia national
guard from virginia and a whole bunch of
other law enforcement authorities
start to redirect people and to uh
get them get them away so
a lot a lot going on and we are going to
have continued coverage and as
i've said before i believe the most
important thing here
aside of course from people not getting
hurt
and all of that and unfortunately a
woman who was shot inside the capitol
has died um is that the vote has to
continue
and we cannot you know they delayed this
certainly by some hours and it was going
to be in many hours anyway because of
the
objections that we were going to be
hearing um
we the count needs to resume and they
can't be allowed to actually
interfere with this process that's the
most important
thing um okay let me do something so
here this i was going to just do this
real quick but it's now
turning into something um even
even bigger uh
i have an apology to make because
earlier today i
incorrectly said that a stream from a
channel we were watching was a trumpist
channel
the channel we were watching is called
status coup
i in the chaos of it said i think this
is a trumpist channel and that was wrong
we were flipping back and forth between
a bunch of these streams
many of them were protesters with
cameras one of them was not
one of them was a channel status coup i
was wrong
i messed up guys and i'm owning up and
taking responsibility
status coup is not a trumpist channel
there is no uh hedging of any
kind i just said something that was not
right and i apologize to you for that
now un unfortunately
um this has now started to get into one
of these things
where the guy who runs the channel
jordan sharadon tweeted to me just
before i went live
and like i just don't need the we don't
need the ad hominems we
i mistakenly said that they were a
trumpist channel
i was wrong and i'm apologizing but then
you see stuff like this
i don't recall david reporting in flint
michigan 17 times that's true
i didn't i that's not what i do i mean
and people who do it i think are
absolutely brave
and valuable and fantastic if this
individual did that
i think that that's fantastic um or
being arrested for covering things okay
that's that's fair yeah i haven't done
that stuff i don't that's not what i do
um and then i really have only ever seen
him
audition for msnbc
i mean that's it's just kind of an ad
hominem you know we really don't need
that and as i pointed out here
an honest mistake was made and i am
about to correct it on air when i go
live in five minutes
the ad hominems are unnecessary i made a
mistake
and in good faith we'll correct it so
oh and there's another one here um it's
ironic you just suggested an ad hominem
attack when you go on air talking about
channels journalists you apparently
don't know do better
again see this is this is exactly like
this is exactly when things are just
people are just being mad
i i'm owning up to it you know i made a
mistake and
uh i don't see the point of you know i'm
i'm sorry guys i
i just said something wrong and i just
don't get when
this this this stuff doesn't seem
productive to me
and i'm getting you know pings from um
you know all sorts of uh i guess these
are sort of like
revolutionary leftists who i mean
it's just it's just a mistake guys you
know and if this is
it's like look we've got an armed
insurrection going on in washington d.c
we've uh democrats have taken the senate
there's so much going on we've got a
global pandemic
i'm not here to hide i'm apologizing i'm
apologizing i'm saying i made a mistake
and i'm sorry status coup and jordan
sharadon
are not trumpists i was wrong i'm
admitting the mistake
and uh when this stuff escalates it's a
real waste of time so that's
my i've i've given my apology and we are
we are moving on and certainly people
will not be
uh satisfied with that and that's okay
it's really not a big deal
okay now as the violence grew
in washington dc donald trump put out
a video put out a video
and um the video is telling protesters
to go home
and yet is repeating the exact same
lies that made the protesters show up
and get violent in the first place
check this out i know you're paying i
know you're hurt
we had an election that was stolen
from us so that's not true that's not
true
it was a landslide election and everyone
knows it
especially the other side but you have
to go home now
it wasn't a landslide but now he says
you have to go home well but you're
inciting them with the same stuff that
got him there in the first place
we have to have peace we have to have
law and order we have to respect
our great people in law and order
we don't want anybody hurt it's a very
tough period of time
there's never been a time like this
where
such a thing happened where they could
take it away from all of us
from me from you from our country oh wow
and i'm being told twitter has deleted
the video is that true
oh my god they did they took it down
altogether
wow wow and then he had also tweeted
this but i guess this uh before we
before i refresh let's just read it
because it was removed
these are the things and events that
happen when a sacred landslide
election victory is so unceremoniously
and viciously stripped away from great
patriots
who have been badly and unfairly treated
for so long oh
he's essentially defending the violence
this is the president defending the
violence
go home with love and in peace remember
and if i refresh
let's see the tweet's gone the tweet
violated wow
so listen guys it's very clear that
twitter is taking
a dramatically different approach now uh
to donald trump
and we've been wondering is it possible
that he is going to
uh get banned altogether from twitter
when he's no longer president
if that's any indication uh the answer
would would probably be yes
so we are monitoring what is taking
place in washington dc let's listen to
what the washington post is saying and
the real question is
when will the house and senate reconvene
and just finish this
what is typically a ceremonial process
of
um of of uh counting the ballots that
have already been
been certified by states supporters
diehard trump dead enders
uh are you don't believe
uh that the legislature is a co-equal
branch to the executive
and they don't believe that the the
legislative branch should be able to
to thwart trump uh and and so
i mean these are these are these are
autocratic
anti-democratic uh rioters who are
trying to
you know anarchists who are trying to to
bring down
the the very system of government that
that is
uh you know worked for us for 220 some
years
amber phillips let's go to you on the
breaking news that speaker nancy pelosi
is asking colleagues to proceed tonight
at the u.s capitol there we go
it is cleared for use important continue
the work they began
uh at one o'clock this afternoon that's
what we've been waiting on that's right
uh our colleague mike dubonis just
reported on a statement she sent out
to house lawmakers um she calls today a
shameful assault made on our democracy
and said she's consulted with top her
fellow top democrats in the house
as well as defense department leadership
the military the pentagon
as well as the justice department as
well as the vice president
uh of course not the president himself
with the vice president
and she says quote we have decided we
should proceed tonight at the capitol
once it is cleared
beautiful and she tells the house
lawmakers will be sending
all guidance on what this means uh
this is fascinating libby that we have
been hearing reporting and we and
we saw tweets from even some trump
allies senator lindsey graham
uh in south carolina saying or just
feeling this
need to finish what was what was
horrifically
interrupted uh right as it got started a
reminder that this happened
right as the first challenge came in i'm
not saying there was any coordination
understanding but this is just what
happened right as the first challenge
came
to the first state arizona's legitimate
electoral results
mitch mcconnell just given this like 10
minutes all right so it appears as
though they are going to try to go back
and and continue the counting and i
think that that's important and that
absolutely
uh should should happen and we are going
to stand by for that
so consider what it is that has taken
place now we have seen donald trump
essentially denounce mike pence donald
trump earlier tweeting
and in fact we can pull up that tweet
just to get everybody
centered with what it is that has taken
place a bunch of trump tweets already
deleted
uh where was it wow a bunch of stuff was
deleted that's incredible
oh it looks like they deleted even the
pence tweet
it must be this one that is unbelievable
trump tweeting
earlier that mike pence let them down
essentially mike pence
failed because he didn't do more to try
to steal the election so
trump has denounced pence uh
there's nothing pence can do this is
merely ceremonial joe biden has won
twitter is now actively removing a bunch
of the things that donald trump is
posting
this is essentially the political
equivalent of a dead man walking
and um it is i can't think of a more
humiliating
moment for the united states in terms of
the fundamentals of our of our of our
democracy and
and what this is built on and there are
now
um there there is the idea of drafting
articles of impeachment
very quickly i i mean it's warranted
you're not going to get anything done
before trump leaves office i think
it's abundantly clear that this guy
can't even really do another 15 days or
however many it is 14
13 and a half days at this point in time
this is a man
that was always unfit to lead and it is
just
stunning that we are still even saying
well can he actually do the job
can he do the job no of course he can't
and
it is um a global shame
and global embarrassment let's look at
some of the reporting on what's been
taking place
violently clashing with the police
earlier in the day one of
the buildings had been evacuated when
protesters breached the perimeter
and then somehow they breached the
security perimeter of
the game somehow and they started
breaking down windows running amok in
statuary hall
eventually got onto the senate floor and
the house floor and then you know the
vice president was evacuated by secret
service
and then someone was shot and it's my
understanding
that that person has has died i mean
that that is the cost
of what has happened today i mean
someone died in the united states
capital
so i'm being told i'm getting some
messages that
i'm getting conflicting message i won't
even go into the detail i'm getting
conflicting messages about how quickly
the counting may resume
let me just put it that way we don't
even need to get into the specifics of
of the timing but
i'm getting everything from it could be
very soon to it
it might not be until 10 or even 11 pm
tonight and it's ultimately going to
depend on how quickly they get things
cleared because as you can see
even though there is a 6 pm curfew and
the headline is that police are clearing
the mob
a lot of these people have no
significant urgency to get out of here
and the other thing to remember is if
indeed we are still going to see the
number of objections that were expected
uh in six states in total and we were
only about a half hour into the first
state you get two hours of debate for
each state that is objected to
this as it was could have lasted until
two or three in the morning if they were
not going to break
so it's completely plausible that this
will continue
into tomorrow or even the next day so to
some degree
to some degree the insurrec
insurrectionists
will have gotten what they wanted at
this point it it it is likely going to
be a significant delay
however and a lot of people in the chat
are pointing out something that's
important
will republicans after this say you know
what
trump's off the deep end trump has
denounced pence
we're really more on the pens side and
we're going to stop the objections
we know it's inevitable we know we can't
stop joe biden that would be the smart
thing to do for republicans at this
point in time
and to not continue with two hours of
debate
for six different six different states
that would be absolutely bonkers
but remains to be seen and step one
would be
just the resumption of the joint session
let me do a couple of thank yous i do
want to say thanks to the 21
21 people who just grabbed twitch
subscriptions i appreciate that
i also want to say thanks to the people
that are signing up on my website
which uh what is the number of people
doing that hold on a second
i want to say thanks to the six people
who signed up at joinpakman.com
putting us at 27. i really do
i really do very much appreciate that i
see a lot of people asking if a lot of
people have been banned today
unfortunately yeah i i think it's
conceivable that hundreds of people
have been banned today um on
youtube and twitch and it's sad there's
everything from
insurrection supporters whoa this is
weird
insurrection supporters coming in every
every combination of things we've seen
and we did have to ban um many many
people
uh okay sage says how is there not a
slew of arrests happening during this
yeah i think there's only been about 10
arrests can somebody fact check that
i think only 10 arrests so far it makes
no sense
dt asking is today the death of the
republican party
i can't imagine anything democrats could
have done that would have been worse for
republicans than what republicans did
today
13 arrests so far okay if you say
is there anything democrats could have
done today that would have more damage
the republican party
than the self-inflicted damage
republicans did i can't think of
anything now whether there will be
long-term damage remains to be seen
mullen just on msnbc saying it's not
anyone's fault
but the rioters and that he believes
they aren't real trump supporters oh
well that i mean
i don't know about that that that opens
the door to saying they're actually
left-wingers
and there's no evidence of that
whatsoever
uh hey david saludos the mendoza if they
impeach trump now he will be invalidated
from running in 2024. that is worth it
right i'm not sure about i don't know
about that if that's the case i'm not
sure what law
uh that would that would be related to
and mike says to anyone in the comments
who think trump supporters will wake up
from this
just go to our conservative and see for
yourself
there's a lot of delusion happening in
some of those enclaves of the internet
yeah no question no question at all tell
us your thoughts on what's going to
happen next well
eventually this will be cleared order
will be restored and joe biden
is going to receive 306 electoral votes
in the uh joint session of the house and
senate it's a question of how long it's
going to take
it's that simple uh it's it's a question
of
does it happen late tonight early
tomorrow late tomorrow does it carry
over into friday
i don't know how long it's going to take
but that is the next step and in the
midst of it there will probably be some
more violence
and some additional number of arrests i
think i saw twitter take down a trump
tweet they did they took down so if
you're just joining us donald trump
posted
a video yesterday i'm sorry um hours ago
and a tweet they are both gone the tweet
that was here
essentially says the violence from his
supporters
uh is warranted this tweet was a video
in which trump said um that it's time to
go home
but they stole the election and we won
in a landslide
and then earlier this tweet which was
removed was one in which
he denounced mike pence that donald
trump has now denounced his
own vikes vice president and it is an
incredible day it is just
incredible that this is what is going on
at this point
let's get an and i like twitter's
approach which is
we're not even going to wait for him to
be gone we're going to we're going to
get going now
um let's take a listen and see what nbc
news is up to
democracy of decency honor
respect the rule of law
just plain simple decency right
that was biden earlier now in recent
weeks we've seen joe biden increasingly
step into this apparent leadership
void delivering addresses to the nation
about the pandemic about the tough
economy
and now this crisis in our democracy and
as
asked by reporters biden said he wasn't
concerned about his own safety his own
security or even his own inauguration
indeed which is set to happen at the u.s
capitol outside
in two weeks time a lot of conversation
about that in light of what has happened
here all right jeff
thank you and we noted that curfew now
underway and washington police have been
working to disperse the rioters from the
capitol
and what's weird is that despite the
curfew
there's no big urgency i don't know if
this is someone who's hurt or what's
going on but
there's very little urgency even though
we're 45 minutes into this curfew
um p it's almost like an
it's almost like the encampments that
these very trump supporters were
denouncing when they were taking place
over the summer
and essentially no urgency here and
sometimes when you look at crowd control
even though the curfew is at six they
work slowly to avoid
acute incidence so as long as people are
relatively corralled here
and sort of drifting out and they can
get the capital itself more and more
under control
that's why there may be no particular
urgency to get to get people dispersed
at this point in time
um but uh cnn saying chuck schumer says
8 p.m 8 p.m for the resumption i'm being
told to check out
uh caitlyn collins twitter see what
she's saying
okay hearing that despite today's events
president trump doesn't want his
republican allies to drop their efforts
to object to biden's win there's been
some discussion among republican
senators about abandoning it that would
be smart
but trump wants them to keep fighting it
to be determined
what they'll do uh okay
robert o'brien said i just spoke with
vice president pence he's a genuinely
fine and decent man
he exhibited courage today and caitlyn
collins says this is significant the
national security adviser who often
closely
aligns with trump defends pence and says
he showed courage today
a direct criticism of trump saying he
didn't
so what it the the gist of what
i'm understanding is that there is an
effort being made
to get uh consensus
uh generated so that republican senators
feel okay abandoning their efforts to
wildly contest
these results which of course will go
nowhere ultimately it's going to fail
and that that seems to be what is going
on donald trump
has been putting pressure on people for
two months now
to do this to do that to do the other
thing anything they can
um and it's becoming increasingly clear
that they are looking for escape pods
and maybe senators
who were planning to object in
pennsylvania to the pennsylvania vote
and to the georgia vote it's certainly
conceivable that they are sort of
looking for the escape pod
you could call it rats jumping the
rotten ship as some are people saying
uh or or an escape pod to not have to do
that anymore and when you see robert
o'brien say pence did the right thing
now that trump has denounced pence it
seems very plausible that that's exactly
what uh what we are going to see
let's read a few other super chats as we
stand by here
84 percent of cops voted for trump in
2016
is it crazy to think they would treat
trump as differently than black lives
matter
no uh in a theoretical sense it's not
i don't believe trump will run again
he'll have don jr run and then trump
will campaign for don jr maybe
maybe will today be looked at the same
way pearl harbor 911 and the jfk
assassination are looked at
i think anybody claiming to know the
answer to that it's just too soon to say
i don't think we can i don't think we
can say yet trump's deleted tweets can
be seen here
a lot was deleted today alone yeah we
might look at that tomorrow
david how do you think the breach was
allowed to happen do you think someone
in the trump administration was behind
the lack security
that's sort of conspiratorial i have no
evidence for that
i have no evidence for that at this
point bbc have new updates saying the
woman shot at the protest has died yeah
i reported that earlier that is true
my brother was at the protest earlier
and was part of the mob that invaded the
capital oh my goodness
i am truly disgusted and ashamed i feel
for you gt
that's absolutely horrifying jenny via
twitch says love the show thanks for all
you do
appreciate that jenny thank you very
much um also andre checking in
uh jay zakari says via twitch
america will survive this coup coup
attempt remember coup attempt
um i believe that you are right
but i think that it is going to get very
ugly for a period of time
and uh oh let's hear from raphael
warnock incoming senator senator elect
who are willing to do anything to stay
in power
and this is the extreme expression of
that
but for too long in washington we've had
uh politicians who are so focused on the
next
election that they're not thinking about
the next generation
and this is uh the kind of of
craven um uh act
that we we're witnessing right now for
the sake of
of of positioning oneself for a
presidential election four years from
now
is shameful it's way beyond the pale
uh and the folks who have participated
in this uh
today uh who have aided and abetted this
kind of
uh action uh will be remembered
by history this this terrible moment
in the life of our country it's a dark
moment but you know even in the midst of
that darkness
there are glimpses of light and i'm very
proud of the people of georgia they
elected
an african-american pastor of
dr king's church the first black senator
from georgia
and a young jewish man the son of an
immigrant
a mentee of john lewis in this defining
moment in our story reminding us
of the covenant that we have with one
another what an upgrade
right i mean replacing kelly leffler
with this gentleman and replacing david
perdue
with the other gentleman john ossoff the
these are dramatic
upgrades the these are not trivial
changes
uh to the senate and of course the fact
that it puts the balance of power at 50
50 meaning kamala harris gets to be vote
number 51
on anything uh where democrats have 50
50 votes
you you can't possibly overstate the
importance of this
cheated out of his election at this
election
led to what happened at the capitol well
there'll be time to
to think about that and um look
i think it's a mistake for us as a
country when we take stock of what's
happened over the last few years
if we extract donald trump from
that equation i think we miss an
important moment for the country we
can't talk about him
without regard to what gave birth to him
if we remove them from the equation um
the the top right so very very important
very important day with two important
wins for democrats
i'm told fox news is going completely
anti-trump right now so let's actually
check that out i'm curious what is going
to be going on
uh with with fox news let's take a look
that would be pretty damn funny if they
are going fully anti-trump
um i did allow ads on fox let's see if
we can get going here
um that they may be able to get back in
session
in the next hour and a half or so all
right mike we'll head back for
any details back with the panel byron um
i think the
the what's that a lot of people have is
about security
and about the capitol police you know
why didn't they know this was a
possibility
they deal with tons and tons of protests
all the time
washington riot siege kind of a lot of
people all at once
can overwhelm security quickly and
we just don't have a sense of what what
the situation was
no and believe me there is going to be a
commission
to investigate the events of this day i
feel
absolutely certain to expand a little
bit on what mike was just reporting
this effort this republican effort to
challenge the electoral college results
is just blown up in their face uh
because of these
events today there were really two
different kind of efforts in the house
and in the senate
uh a lot of people in the house really
did want to overturn the result
change the result of this election so it
does seem that fox news i mean listen
fox news's priority is self-preservation
right so they are going to do everything
they can trump is clearly on the outs
trump has denounced pence pence
really is like the traditional
republican party whereas trump is this
uh uh thing that appeared in 2016
and the republican party will go back to
being if trump does
go away uh more of what pence is
associated with so fox news clearly
making the calculation and starting to
kind of pivot in a sense to being hey
yeah we're kind of like back to being
what we were doing george w bush and
barack obama
so i wouldn't chalk it up to anything
other than they realize the trump ship
is sinking very quickly they can't
possibly bail out water quickly enough
to stay afloat
unless they throw trump over the edge
and lighten the load to get to kind of
use the
um seafaring seafaring analogy and i
think that's exactly what is going on
right now
get back to talking about obama's tan
suit or the tan sweater i wore the other
day they'll be far better suited
um i think with uh with with that type
of thing
a big thank you to mateo
tony riley b prpb
wolves gristly knuckle holy [ __ ]
um and a whole bunch of other people an
additional
12 folks grabbing twitch subs which i
really appreciate putting us
at uh 39 and then
also um an additional 12 website members
which brings us to 51. i will in this
second stream of the day
i will open phone lines if we get to a
hundred
and um i would love to hear from some of
you guys about everything that's going
on as of right now
we are told that around about an hour
from now around 8 p.m is when we are
expecting the senate
and house to reconvene and to start
counting the votes
uh once again um about an hour
from now some other super chats people
want trump arrested
past pastel bell says david thank you
for your amazing and diligent coverage
you've been a stable voice so uncertain
times
brian says maga just lives by a
different set of rules we get to vote
you don't we get to have supreme court
justices you don't
we get to riot you don't we get to win
elections and you don't yeah
essentially essentially i'm told that
things are happening with mike pence's
twitter
let's take a look at that mike pence
okay i'm not seeing anything within the
last
three hours
um maybe you met the official account
which is uh there's a different one hold
on vice president mike pence the vp
let's see if you mean that one just
retweeting
yeah not seeing anything new i think
we're basically up to speed on the
things that
that mike pence has been putting up
there he unfollowed trump yeah
oh wait hold on look at the banner at
the top what's the banner at the top
um oh the other account the top
banner
uh
okay what am i looking at here
the banner is pence and his wife okay
i don't get it what are we looking at
is that weird okay all right we're
moving on i i'm sorry i don't understand
what's notable about mike pence having a
picture of himself and his wife
um there at uh at the top of his
at the top of his profile um okay let's
listen to a little more of
raphael warnock uh senator elect my
neighbor coughs
they might be sick today but because
they're my neighbor in there
and they coughed i i might be imperiled
that doesn't make my neighbor my enemy
that means that i've got to have my
neighbors back
that if they're uncovered perhaps i'm
unprotected i should want them to have
health care
i should want their children to have
access
to a quality education i should want
them to be able to work with dignity and
earn a livable wage
and to retire i should want
for them equal protection
under the law and um
uh tonight as we watch these rioters
storm our capital
um without uh and and we watch the
response of law enforcement
and juxtapose that to what happens
uh when black and brown people whether
they're in ferguson or
baltimore and other places have risen up
non-violently
uh to give voice to their concerns it's
a market study in contrast that's hard
to ignore
and i think it calls us in this moment
to build a kind of multi-racial
coalition of conscience
that i think we saw this summer in light
of the tragic flash points of george
floyd and others
we saw americans of all colors genera
multi-generationally march out into the
streets
um massed up against one virus
covet 19 in order to wage war against
the virus of bigotry and racism
and xenophobia we need that kind of
spirit and we need it now more than ever
reverend rafael warnock who made history
today
by becoming the first black american
elected united states senator from the
state of georgia
congratulations senator on your
hard-fought win thank you so much for
joining us
thank you so much how are you wow
wow and we turn again to our lisa
desjardins now at the capitol where we
are hearing that lawmakers will resume
the electoral college count process
oh wait a sec what jimmy dore attacked
me let me look at that jimmy dore
attacked me oh he did oh i'm gonna like
it
i always i always just like jim when
jimmy dore attacks me
i i get the instinct i'm doing something
right
check this out jimmy see i knew i knew
that
that the revolutionary left was going to
go after this let's see
oh look yeah look at this so oh my
goodness this is just
so sad all i can do is like it
so earlier this guy named jordan
sharadon
was mad at me because i mistakenly said
his channel was a trumpet channel
earlier today in the midst of a live
stream i i was wrong to do that
i i apologized at the top of the stream
and as you can see i said it was an
honest mistake i'm about to correct it
and then i guess he didn't like my
apology and he said
i i guess i'm just a bad person i don't
know so then now
jimmy dore seized on it
and says yes david i i
is well now no faux progress
progressive and red baiting defender of
status quo
who always punches left and
mccarthy smears his political opponents
mccarthy doesn't mccarthy smears mean
calling people socialists and communists
isn't that what mccarthy smearing is
isn't i
i'm the one who says it's stupid to
attack people as being socialist when
they're not
david al pacman is that like islamist
like as if i was is
a muslim
i don't even know what this is can
someone tell me what it means to
mccarthy smear people
does that mean i call people communists
is it alpaca because i'm argentinian
al pacman like alpaca
i don't even know yes communist
wow that's crazy i'm just gonna retweet
it
retweet um
i don't even get that david alpachmann
is a red baiting defender of status quo
who punches left and mccarthy smears his
political opponents
i feel like i do the opposite of
mccarthy smearing
in that i say we shouldn't call people
socialists and communists as an insult
if they are not
socialists and con this is very
interesting
this is very interesting oh look at this
this is how look at this
jonathan patrick patrick david said he
would vote blue no matter who
even if it was david duke and was
running against richard spencer
no that i never said that that's so
insane what i said was there's
you always have a choice there's always
a worse person
i can't i don't know who this is but i
can't think of a more dishonest framing
i was once asked even if the choices
were david duke and richard spencer
which would you vote for
and i think i said if you come to me and
you say one of these two men will be
president
i would choose duke over spencer because
spencer's much more
articulate and and sophisticated in his
speech
and would probably convince more people
about his white nationalism whereas
david duke is so gross and vile
he would probably be more ineffective
the point i was trying to make was
this idea of two bad choices versus a
good and a bad or whatever
we can always as adults think about
which one is worse and my view was there
are reasons why i think spencer is
probably more difficult
and as people are pointing out it was
kind of a trap question to begin with
but anyway guys this is really the worst
of the worst of the left and i don't
even know if this stuff is left i mean
you guys tell me um
and then again the blue no matter who i
don't even know what that means
neat i don't know what are these peop
david duke and richard spencer what
political party are they i don't think
it has nothing to do with party
yeah i should even get away from it it's
really really weird
but i'm still curious david alpachmann
like is that
is that an argentinian joke because of
argentinian
alpacas or is it like david al pacman
like as if i have a muslim last name
even though i'm jewish i don't
i wish i understood it a.i like i'm an
a.i
like i'm i'm not i'm not i'm an ai or
something
holy [ __ ] i don't know guys but anyway
you know when i talk about the left
doing things that are weird that's kind
of what i'm um
what i'm talking about i think the ai
means artificial intelligence
the ai pacman it's a oh it's a reference
to a i
a pack he was being anti-semitic towards
you oh yeah i
have nothing to do with aipac aipac is
an american israeli lobby
i have nothing to do with them i've i've
never had anything to do with them i've
never praised them or anything like that
um so that's that's even weird it's
anti-semitic i didn't realize i had no
idea i thought he was saying like
david alpaca alpaca man or something
like that
really weird okay trump's twitter
account will be locked for 12 hours
ladies and gentlemen trump twitter
locked trump twitter locked let's
refresh
uh after having three tweets deleted
today
donald trump has received a 12-hour
ban a 12-hour ban
on twitter because of he his spreading
of
election related disinformation so
twitter seems to be taking the trump
tweets
significantly more seriously and
i think that that's that's really really
great let's go back to lisa desjardins
and see what's uh what she's up to
it's been a tumultuous afternoon you've
been there
in the middle of it um from the very
beginning
uh fill us in on where we are and where
we go from here
currently capitol police have say that
they have secured
the capitol building beautifully right
now i'm at a house office building this
is where we see
really the residents of capitol hill the
members of congress and their staff
have been sheltering in place we are
under lockdown that means no one can
leave
no one can enter this building at the
same time we are seeing some movement
toward
the house chamber i've seen the house
clerk
and some of nancy pelosi the speaker's
aides go that direction how's it going
as we just reported passed me a short
while ago uh
going up not necessarily to the capitol
but
talking to a leadership source with
house democrats a member who is in
leadership
they told me that that they will come
back tonight reconvene
i said when eight o'clock nine o'clock
you know this person said we haven't
decided yet i don't want to give you a
time
but yeah that sounds about right
interesting another staffer made a good
observation though judy that
it could be an hour from now for several
hours
so the hope is to return soon
but we don't know because the issue is
judy they have to
clean the house chamber um there are
code bid concerns
and of course there it is disrupted
i want to show some video right now i
think that we have it of the evacuation
of the house
chamber oh we don't have it i'm sorry
but
police did quickly evacuate the chamber
but with weapons drawn
which was something that i saw as well
when police confronted
protesters on the third floor of the
capitol
but the determination now from leaders
in both chambers
is to continue with the certification
and finalization of the 2020 election
tonight beautiful
you see members of the capitol police
now you know these are folks that have
been standing on guard
in in this particular corridor uh
they're relaxed right now you could hear
some laughing even
but i talked to a different capital
police officer who had a very scuffed up
jacket
and clearly with someone who got pushed
around with protesters and you know i
joked oh you should take some aspirin
and he said yeah i think
i think i really might tomorrow and
that's probably the last thing i want to
say is
having observed the protesters
crash through the front door of the u.s
capitol
one thing that i feel like hasn't been
talked about a lot i've heard some of
our guests have talked about
capitol police and their concerns about
what capitol police did not do
but i want to talk about i did see a
lone capital police officer just one
unarmed or he didn't draw a weapon if he
had one
throw his body into the gap of the front
door of the u.s capitol trying to stop
the protesters by himself wow not
another officer with him
um and and it was a courageous thing to
do
of course why were there not more police
with him there were a few on the other
side
trying to get in but i just want to
point out that there were capital police
who were running into the crowd to try
and protect the capitol
and lisa i think i remember that moment
because you were on you know
standing on a balcony inside the capitol
looking
down on the door where the protesters
the mob was coming in
breaking glass trying to push through
the door a truly truly unbelievable day
people are asking about the woman that
was shot
at the capitol she has died she has died
indeed
and that is very very sad um
big thank you to an additional 21
twitch subscribers which puts us at 72
very much appreciate your support and
also an additional eight
members at joinpackman.com putting us at
80.
i think we'll open the phone lines if
and when we get to 100 members at
joinpakman.com
because i haven't heard from anybody
today and i think that that
would be a good thing to hear what is
what is on everybody's minds
uh yeah i see people in the chat telling
me jimmy dore attacked me i know i know
we already i already
liked it and retweeted it you know
beyond that i don't really care too much
about it but i i liked it and retweeted
it
and i didn't really understand it but we
did already address that okay so we're
not gonna go
um fully fully back to that at this
point in time
the curfew has started in dc we're
already 71 minutes into the curfew
and no real rush from police officers to
get everybody
out of there um but slowly but surely
it appears as though um people are
are calming down and they have sort of
re-secured
um the some of the area at least the
capital
check april ryan's tweet about the 25th
amendment okay let's check that out
um april ryan i think it's april d
ryan yep there it is
april d ryan american carnage
robocall congressional leaders are in
the undisclosed location
and are and focusing on the 25th
amendment to get donald trump
out of office if that is true
that would be absolutely wild um
let's do it that is if true huge if true
absolutely huge if true that is
unbelievable
uh twitter has locked trump's account
for 12 hours for spreading
disinformation we already talked about
that
um democrats have taken control of the
senate thanks to winning both seats in
georgia
50 50 with kamala harris as the
tie-breaking vote
and looks like rioters were destroying
some of the associated press's equipment
let's see
wow
very friendly just destruction of
property
video taken earlier today as trump
supporters
damaged equipment owned by media
organizations
we'll certainly be watching to see if
those people are prosecuted
right i doubt it james it starts with
the president of the united states
making fun of reporters mocking
reporters mocking a disabled reporter
calling reporters enemies threatening
them making jokes about them dying
tweeting images of them being murdered
and we see it escalate over time
we're seeing that today the theft the
chasing of uh
of journalists who are just doing their
job and
uh the destruction of their equipment
yeah and dehumanization is really what
it is that
you know those guys uh yep they really
should arrest every single one of them
that's the that's the path forward as
far as i'm concerned
um as we continue to keep an eye on what
is taking place and it looks like we're
actually getting much closer here to the
resumption let's take a listen
uh okay wow they'll take their seats
wow so the count they're getting the
order the getting the count resumed this
is absolutely huge they are resuming the
count
the armed insurrectionist violent
outrageous lunatics are not going to
prevent what needs to happen from
happening that is
excellent excellent news oh wait this
was earlier
no this is live according to i don't
know why it says 2 15.
okay we can get order we can resume
resume he's saying resume so i think
this is live i just think that that's
wrong where it says 2 15.
they are resuming the count my friends
they are resuming the count
um i do want to say thank you to the
additional
seven people who just signed up at
joinpackman.com
and we also just dropped in another 25
twitch subscribers uh which puts us
at 112. so once they resume we will open
up some phone lines i want to hear from
some of you guys
uh you'll be able to call in via discord
davidpakman.com
slash discord okay davidpakman.com
discord you can get into the waiting
lobby
and uh we will we will take some calls
once they resume i want to hear a little
bit about how the process resumes here
and unfortunately i think that they go
back
to the debate about arizona objections i
don't think they go back to just
campaign
the chair declares the house in recess
pursuant to clause 12b
of rule one okay now they're back in
recess
and with that the house went into
reading oh that was earlier
so it was that was not live
that was earlier all right guys well we
i certainly have no idea what's going
what's going on
excuse me um
expecting them to go back in about 45
minutes or so
all right that was a mistake that was a
mistake it was indeed
oh i got a frog in my throat it was
indeed
from uh earlier earlier today okay
let's get to some
callers let's get to some callers
oh we have some nice suit hold on let me
read some nice super chats here
we love you and thank you david f the
haters
nice um
there was one other one hold on
the andrew says the vast majority of
progressives know you're a good person
who has a genuine and intelligent world
view ignore the haters we love you man
thanks andrew i appreciate that
pedro says what's a jimmy door um
a lot of stuff about trump's twitter
okay so a lot a lot of different
messages coming in
all right let's talk to a couple of
people
via um
okay hold on there's so much going on
here via discord as we wait for the
house to resume
davidpakman.com discord let's hear from
just a few people
okay let's go first to
uh caleb from atlanta caleb from atlanta
what's going on
hey what's going on david how you doing
so
one of the primary states in contention
here is georgia and you know
from atlanta from georgia and it's
expected that
kelly lefler will expect to object even
though she just
lost her election right do you think
that she's going to
continue to object like this or do you
think that she's going to follow with
some other
gop senators and drop their objections
along
we don't know yet so that's what's being
that's what's being
wondered about now which is given what's
going on
there are signals being sent to
republicans that basically
we are not behind trump anymore robert
o'brien for example
said he's with pence not trump on the
trump denouncing pence
my understand my read of that is that
these are signals being sent that you
don't have to play the game for trump
anymore
and hopefully they will drop their
objections we just don't know yet we
we're gonna have to wait and see yeah
it's going to be interesting to see how
the republican party shifts away from
trump and how that split is going to
work out
exactly and all that yep
well thanks for taking my call i
appreciate that my pleasure thank you uh
thank you for calling in
let's go next to wyatt from indiana
wyatt from indiana you're on the air
hey how's it going david good thank you
hey uh
so kind of a quick question i don't
really think we'll see anything tonight
do you think we'll see
uh pence invoke the 25th amendment to
kind of
take over now that he's turned away from
trump and everybody
certainly not tonight but there is a
report that is it is being discussed
and at this point i i'm the last person
that would tell
you something definitely will happen or
something definitely won't happen at
this point we are in unprecedented
territory could be anything
okay well thank you stay safe likewise
stay safe
as well um let's go
next to um
why don't we go to brendan from new
jersey you're on the air
hey david can you hear me i can hear you
awesome uh first of all big fan of the
show um and
thanks for taking my call i'm actually a
history teacher i teach uh high school
age students
who are clearly on both sides of this
political issue
okay and i i really struggle to try to
maintain my political neutrality
when teaching current events recently so
an event like today
is hard not to call a violent coup
attempt and an act of sedition so my
question
ultimately is how can someone like me
maintain neutrality
as best as they can and effectively
discuss
with students the important events of
something like today well remember that
neutrality and
objectivity are two different things so
you can be neutral
in that you don't express a value
judgment as to whether
an armed insurrection coup attempt is
good or bad
while not losing objectivity about the
fact that that's what it is now it's
easier said than done
but i think here it comes down to a
difference between objectivity
and neutrality and i think there are
ways for you as a teacher to remain
neutral
while still being objectively accurate
in what you're telling the students
is going on in the world yeah well first
of all
thank you um and uh it's it's something
that you know i'm kind of struggling
with especially recently but i i
appreciate that advice david it's really
meaningful thank you so much my pleasure
thank you uh thank you so much for
calling in
that was a perfect phone call i think i
think that was a perfect phone call
let's go next to
um oh i don't know let's go to
let's go to u.s sailor dani from
ark ark is it arcata california i don't
know where
arc uh hi david can you hear me yes i
can
oh yeah so i'm in the navy but i'm from
arkansas but i'm stationed in california
oh got it okay but yeah
yeah uh so dude i'm a huge fan of the
show thank you thank you much for taking
the call
um it's really nice to talk to you uh so
kind of getting away from everything
that's going on
um i just wanted to ask you how likely
you think biden will embrace like a
truly
progressive leftist policies one thing
i've been paying attention to is his
appointing of janet yellen as secretary
of treasury
right and you know a lot of people think
of her maybe as like an establishment
figure or perhaps an institutionalist
and i'm not sure that that's very
hopeful for progressives but i've been
really interested lately
in modern modern uh monetary theory and
maybe there's a chance we embrace that
maybe more so
and i mean i don't we do we don't care
about defense
deficits right now i mean at least in
the past four years but right
republicans are going to go back to that
of course that's going to change so
what are you looking at in terms of
indications of joe biden's
progressiveness and embracing
more left-leaning policies well listen
we have to first manage expectations joe
biden is no
great progressive but if he's able to do
the things he campaigned on he would do
some of the most progressive things any
president has done and it's about
holding him to a
to account on those things i do think
that it's important to say
that janet yellen is one of the picks i
like
best that joe biden has made and you
have to remember
it's joe biden selecting a treasury
secretary it's going to be someone that
generally speaking believes
in a monetary theory
it's going to be somebody that believes
in the role of the treasury but if you
go back and i did a segment about this
janet yellen is a pretty astute
economist
with some very interesting ideas uh she
has a paper from 1990 or 93 called the
fair wage hypothesis which is very
interesting and i did an outline of it
in a segment a few weeks ago so i think
it's
we we have to manage expectations and
understand that you know
biden's not going to pick the equivalent
of marx to run treasury
given what we would expect from biden i
think janet yellen is a great pick and
there's picks that are not so good like
near a tandem and i've i've talked about
that before
right awesome uh thank you david uh
thank you for all that you do
um yeah i'm looking forward for the show
thank you well thank thank you for your
service and can you say are
are you are you on any kind of equipment
can you say what kind of equipment
you're on
uh i'm just at a squadron right now i
deployed to
you know ships um in japan but yeah
that's
pretty much nothing nothing too crazy
seasickness are you no seasickness for
you
uh no seasickness for me uh i've been
unemployment
in about a year though no but oh okay
but you don't have a history of it
you're saying
oh no no no no no not at all and let me
ask you this for people who do get
seasick
if you just stay on the boat does do you
eventually get accustomed or are there
people that never get accustomed
uh i've i i'm sure there are people that
just really never adjust
and you know in that case they would be
flown off the ship but eventually
uh if it were to come to that they just
wouldn't be on a ship anymore but
for the most part you know it's just
they give you some uh
dramamine and send you to your rack and
you're
yeah that's it sure very good all right
thank you so much for the call
yeah thank you so much all right there
it is uh we're hearing from a bunch of
different people at davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go
next to uh let's go to alan from
shanghai
alan from shanghai you're on the air
hi can you hear me yes i can wow
um such an honor to talk to you
the honor is all mine um so my question
is a bit more
i guess meta um and it's about
twitch and kind of like um
the sites you've been streaming on i was
wondering if
you ever thought about um dedicating
specifically to one site because i feel
like
um i don't know some of your
commentaries so sharp
and you know i do like other
commentators like hassan
um and destiny on um
on the site but i i really feel like if
you
uh had a consistent schedule on there
you could easily get
you know 10 to 20 000 subs
and i'm not sure how that compares or uh
against your other income i'm sure you
uh do get
a lot of um you know memberships from
youtube
and whatnot but right i was wondering
your thoughts on that
yes the idea would be by the way is this
stephen kenneth destiny benell the
second
um it may be it may be okay uh i i think
that
the move would be doing some additional
maybe twitch exclusive stuff would be
the idea but
you know abandoning platforms that are
so built up i mean like just to give you
a a sense just in the 50 minutes i've
been streaming
we've had 305 000 different people start
the stream on youtube
and that's that's a lot of people and to
forgo that
you know it could be years before we
made that up
literally years definitely so you know
it's all uh it's all pluses and minuses
i guess you would say
yeah uh it's been an absolutely crazy
day i
i still can't believe what just happened
um
kind of shocking but it's insane great
to talk to you
my pleasure thank you there's uh um
a perfect phone call from shanghai
shanghai i think it's shanghai china
might be shanghai ohio though i'm not
sure
and that's a joke by the way i'm just
kidding around let's go
to justin from milwaukee justin from
milwaukee
what's going on hey david can you hear
me yes i can
excellent so uh thanks for taking my
call pleasure know i'm
i'm i'm watching your stream earlier and
i gotta say like it just
it it it felt i haven't felt
this sense of of drama and and kind of
you know sadness since uh 911 happened
yeah it's true
it's a tragedy it really is it's it's
one of these things that i
i just have to wonder like uh is there
going to be
the kind of pullback um from the
republican party
to this more extremist positions that
they've been taking do you see that as
something that could
honestly happen over the next couple
years it could happen and and
again you're starting to see escape
hatches
open for some of these republicans as
trump has now denounced pence
there are republicans who are who are
basically saying
are you are you bailing because if you
everybody's feeling it out
if you're bailing i'm bailing oh well
maybe if it will
if i bail will you bail and and that
sort of thing and i think we'll get a
little bit of a sense of it later when
we see if the republicans still object
to all six states they plan to object to
and and speaking of pence you know where
do you kind of see him falling
after today's events too i mean he's a
you know career politician he's got to
think
you know what's what's next for him that
i don't know that i really don't know
but uh i think that this may be exactly
what pence needs
to decouple from trump literally two
weeks before he's going to be back out
there as a career politician so i think
it's great for him as well
sure sure well thanks david i appreciate
it and it's great talking to you my
pleasure great to hear from you
um a few super chats i see a lot of
people
saying twitter has suspended trump's
twitter account for 12 hours we we did
report
on that big dog says there's a report
congressional leaders may try to invoke
the 25th amendment that's absolutely
true in that it's
been reported congress april ryan says
congressional leaders are in the
undisclosed location
focusing on the 25th amendment to get
real donald trump
out of office and that would be an
unbelievable thing it would be fantastic
it would be humiliating for trump and
i i'd be lying if i said i wouldn't
love it i would absolutely and
completely love that
let's go next via discord to
let's go to fluffy bunny fluffy bunny
you're on the air
david how are you doing i'm doing well
thank you so
long time listen to your show um after
today
yes how do we
reconcile the kind of
mindset of bringing the other side
into the fold because
it seems to me this is not a side that
wants to be brought in
i don't know the answer i mean it's
there's no
fast answer um and fair enough
part of it is it's a complicated
situation i understand but
but i i understand biden going out there
saying
he's going to be a president for all
america not just blue america
you know um and and that needs to be
said i completely agree
but it seems to me kind of like an
obstinate child that
if you don't want to accept something
you can't force said child to accept
that's exactly right and the the per the
book that is
that that i would refer people to is
dale carnegie's book how to win
friends and influence people which says
one of the best ways to get people
to do what you want them to do is to
make them think
it was their idea in the first place and
that's where it gets to
you need a culture and a cultural and
educational change
where people will say hey here's an idea
how about we do
the stuff we've been talking about for
two decades right and
um that that i think is uh much more
illustrative of what needs to happen
thank you sir i love your show pleasure
thank you fluffy bunny
appreciate hearing from you let's go to
crystal from
connecticut crystal from connecticut
you're on the air
crystal from connecticut oh crystal
baled
that's too bad um all right well no
crystal
let's go to where else are we going to
go let's go to christine
from alberta is that alberta canada
yeah absolutely how are you i'm good how
are you i'm doing well
um i just thought it'd be fun to tell
you all about how in
canada alberta canada where there was
some protests also in calgary
yeah calgary is sort of like the the the
most
if there's anything equivalent to like
american right-wing nuttery it's in
calgary right
um i'd say less so in calgary more so in
edmonton but yeah just alberta in
general is like
more wing and what were they protesting
for or against
they were all about they were all
pro-trump
it was against the election and you know
it's kind of just weird because
what what is their plan what is what are
they trying to accomplish
right right hey here's something i'm
wondering
those folks like in the united states
there's both stereotypes and realities
about the types of jobs that
that like the people that are at this
protest were watching in dc for example
would have
in canada what would be like a typical
job for somebody who shows up
at a protest in calgary uh
oil fields anything in the oil field
interesting
pipefitters generally stuff like that
oil and gas yeah a lot of people in the
chat saying the same thing that's
interesting
okay yeah absolutely yeah so that's the
kind of thing i mean like
outside of this like our biggest news
story lately has just been our mla is
traveling
and so watching everything going on in
the states is just
uh psycho it's completely insane yeah
now let me ask you this is there any
aspect of it that's merely entertaining
or is it always riddled with sort of
like fear and sadness and concern
uh fear sadness and concern because it's
so
possible to happen here in alberta right
yeah wow uh okay well very interesting
thanks for letting me know about that
yeah cool thank you all right thank you
a great call we love hearing from our
canadian friends always
um let's see crystal says hi david this
is crystal from connecticut i
accidentally clicked while unmuting my
mic okay let's see if i can go back to
crystal from connecticut
uh okay crystal from connecticut you are
on
please unmute hi david
thank you so much for answering the call
my pleasure
um what i wanted to ask is with
everything that's happening with trump
today
i actually was at work while listening
to your
to the victor on youtube i've been on
the whole day can we actually prosecute
him for anything
can he be prosecuted afterwards it's
ridiculous the can
can yes will i think the answer is no
that i mean i'm i'm dominican and i've
seen how in a lot of our
latin countries um we've had people like
that like venezuela and everything
bad things really happen it gets insane
so
i mean i'm really hoping that they
actually end up prosecuting him this man
is insane
i agree with you and uh i just i you
know
everything is unprecedented now so i
would never say never but it just
doesn't strike me as something that's
very likely
well i'll be praying because he needs to
be behind bars
yeah i agree with you i don't disagree
and listen maybe they'll end up removing
him
with the 25th amendment in the next two
weeks i also be praying for that too but
i mean i don't even know what this man
gets away with everything he does so i i
have little faith to be yeah absolutely
absolutely
crystal thank you i appreciate it all
right take care
um all right brian from pennsylvania has
been asking to get on for a long long
time
and he sent a super chat so let's see if
i can go to that
pennsylvania there's nothing under
pennsylvania so i'm guessing he probably
put his name
first instead of his location first so
now i've got to go up to b
brian from pennsylvania all right brian
listen you're on
you would better be really good what's
up um david how's it going
it's going well yeah after seeing
everything that's happened i've been
watching your stream since earlier
thank you after i finished class and
i've been a good i've been a huge fan
i had a few questions for you actually
okay
so we understand that this whole
insurrection is
this attempted coup that's been
happening but it's been steering away
from
our major problems with the people
the stimulus checks yeah a lot of people
have been getting the 600
stimulus checks but it just like the
first time that happened college
students
such as myself that i'm a computer
science major wasn't
ineligible for these checks okay
do you see these checks being amended
for the college students as well that
are also
suffering um
i i really don't i really don't it's
possible that if there is a
new stimulus under biden um
it's conceivable it's conceivable
that it would include the college
students but i don't see any
any amending retroactively no you know
being from the hispanic community like i
am hispanic
and it's been rough to see all this
unfold
and if you see these same types of
protests happening from
the blms from the black lives matter yep
happening
in the in the capital like it did today
right
where was the same intensity of the
police force
when trump wanted to um go take a
picture in the church
right right no listen if today had been
black lives matter
the arrests would be in the hundreds not
13 and
really there would probably be more than
one person dead
like this is astonishing to see this
like i'm in a discord we have our own
dedicated news center
yeah and we're watching all this unfold
right and
it's nerve-wracking it gives anxiety
it's insane
i completely agree my my last question
to you is
what do you see happening in the near
future
you know of course the 25th amendment of
course you know hopefully he goes to
jail i understand there's a
fat chance that he will yeah but after
today
does your mindset change of him going
possibly getting criminal charges i
think that
my my belief now that there could be
criminal charges against trump
is the highest it's been at any point in
the last four years but i believe it is
still a very slim chance
hey man i do appreciate you letting me
on i love
i love what you've been doing keep up
the great work man there's not much more
i can ask for
pleasure uh brian from pa very much
appreciate it
let me make sure i'm not falling behind
on other things i want to thank
13 more twitch subscribers who just
signed up via twitch and twitch prime
and
associated uh techniques and also
12 more people who signed up on my
website at joinpakman.com
a few super chats that i want to get to
um
dominic says people have already begun
resigning from trump's sinking ship
i would love to know who i haven't seen
that yet um
rod says radwan from erbil iraq we are
watching in terror
we are praying for your safety wow thank
you
uh is that someone who's holding
radwan from herbal i would i would love
to talk to someone from iraq
uh rad one
no okay that's not someone who's
currently holding did you see some cops
were taking selfies with trumpists
i did hey david my friend sent in a beat
where he remixed the axios donald trump
interview we were wondering if you could
play it
i'm not able to now i i haven't gone
through any of my stuff i i've
you know it's been a busy day been a
very busy day
um
[Music]
flotus chief of staff resigned okay i
mean that's not that's not huge
let's go next to where else do we want
to go
um a variety of different folks here
venezuela argentina alex that looks
interesting what's up with that
venezuela argentina alex
a variety of different folks here oh no
venezuela argentina alex that looks
interesting
you gotta listen on on discord not on
the stream
because it's delayed yeah hello
hi hola hola
oh boy all right and then they just left
wow wow wow wow that's that's sad when
that happens i don't like that
um let's go to zeste from
florida zest stay from florida
greetings can you hear me yes i can i
wasn't
really concerned about how few arrests
have been made
in comparison to some of the other
protests i've seen i know yeah
absolutely
uh it's and again i think if it were uh
if it were a black lives matter protest
it'd be completely different
now hold on one second i'm being told
that mark meadows has resigned is that
true
let's see here latest
uh no that appears not to be the case
okay
don't sorry for the distraction yeah i
mean listen this if this were
an anti-trump protest the arrests and
deaths
would be off the charts and instead
like okay 13 13 people got arrested but
you're completely right in your analysis
this shows the partisanship in the
police force yeah
and also by the way as people are
pointing out it emboldens people to do
this again because very few people got
arrested
exactly anyways cheers keep up the great
work all right
zeste from florida very much appreciate
the call
let's go to cali from wisconsin
hello cali
can you hear me yes i
okay can it going you have to listen in
discord
because otherwise my voice is feeding
back and you're on a huge delay
i thought i was can you hear me okay i
can hear you but how
are you listening in discord now
and they're gone okay wow they just hung
up that's bizarre how that happens
um let's just do a couple more here
let's go to david from scotland david
from scotland you're on the air
oh hello dude one thing listener thanks
for very much for taking my call
good evening
um originally i i wanted to talk about
the idea of trump coming to scotland
yeah but obviously today's events have
um probably taken over the news so i
think it'd be better to ask something
kind of wider
before we go on are you sure that you're
scottish
uh pretty sure okay pretty sure just
making sure because i couldn't tell
you know there is there is more than one
scottish accent yes
um well i i wanted to to ask um
there is still quite a strong
um legacy over the last couple of months
from
the story of trump ignoring
um russian sanctions yes sorry a russian
um bounties bounties
yeah um it's kind of it seems to kind of
dissipated in the u.s but over here
um we kind of see it well i can't talk
for everyone but
a large amount of the scottish
population um kind of sees american
leadership
and being an ally has
severely diminished in the last couple
of years what do you see as
um biden's priorities in re-establishing
the special relationship
i mean i i think it's one of these
things that to some degree will happen
naturally and i know that that's a crazy
thing to say because
how could it just naturally be
reestablished when donald trump has done
so much uh to ruin the relationship and
it seems that there's going to have to
be so much apologizing and
and pleading in that type of thing but
to be to be honest i think diplomatic
relations
um are sort of self-repairing to some
degree
when they're advantageous to both
countries and so i think you know
in a great to a great degree just trump
being gone
and dealing with biden instead is going
to naturally over time
uh uh re-establish that relationship
yeah 100 and um don't don't let any
trumpists
um lie about any kind of
special relationship with scotland he's
got something like an eight percent
approval rating and just because his
mother was
thrown here and we're certainly not a
fan right um
i'd also like to say like just but yeah
i know it doesn't mean much but you know
thoughts and prayers to everything
that's happened in america and i hope
you guys get over it
thank you thank you no we we appreciate
it means a lot and we appreciate it
and uh i appreciate you you know staying
up late with us today
if i may say one extremely controversial
thing please
um it is 100 the case that breakfast
cereal is a soup
and that is a hell that i will die on
breakfast cereal
is a soup i don't disagree
with that i really can't take issue with
that to be perfectly honest
excellent spread the word all right
thank you so much breakfast cereal
is a soup an unbelievable an
unbelievable phone call from scotland
and then now let's go
to luana who i believe hold on a second
is this accurate
luana is calling from san luis in
argentina is that correct
[Music]
oh sorry uh no no so i'll explain i'll
explain no no
so the question is a good one there's in
argentina there's this idea of
essentially
treason against your country a traitor
to your country
and is that something that is going to
become relevant
against donald trump no i don't think so
i think that we'll be lucky
i think the answer is just no i don't
think there's a political will for that
makes sense uh sorry if my english is
kind of rough
no it's great it's great i i would
gladly speak spanish with you the whole
time but i think it would be
frustrating to summon the audience for
everyone yeah i can understand
also since you're from argentina should
i call you
david of course absolutely in spanish
phone calls i'm david
ah great so uh thank you so much
and aguante la milanese absolutamente
mucha gracias
okay luana from san luis argentina
um she just issued a very very strong
endorsement for the chicken milanesa
uh we had a very ugly situation not long
ago where a caller from argentina said
it's all about the beef milanesa i did
not
share that position and it became it
actually got a little bit awkward
to to be totally frank let's go next to
raymie from new york raymie from new
york
thank you very much for calling me thank
you for
picking me my pleasure um let me ask you
this question
um since the since the trump has came to
the capitol
what would happen on the on inauguration
day when joe biden gets inaugurated
um you're saying is it possible that
there will be a repeat of this on
inauguration day
yes because you know how you know the
thing
oh believe me i know so i actually think
that
the the this is going to be a
non-traditional inauguration because of
the virus
so i think that much of it is going i i
think it's going to be sort of like
semi-private i don't know that there's
going to be the ability for people to do
what they did today that that's my
belief as of right now
thank you so i have another question
okay
um
what would happen if twitter banned
trump on
on on inauguration day what trump would
campaign
to get his twitter on unbanned um
that was really an interesting question
in my mind i i
i mean where would he campaign would he
do like rallies saying unban me
yeah you know how he is yeah that's
possible he'll go on parlor or something
like that
hey listen how old a person are you
oh yeah i'm 13. 13. okay wow very good
listen i'm really glad you're engaged
with this stuff and i really appreciate
you uh calling in
yeah just imagine what you'll know at
26.
all right my friend thank you for the
call thank you bye
take care bye wow great people out there
you know there's really great people out
there
um all right let's do
greg from paris in london you're on the
air
oh boy i can barely hear you you're
gonna have to yell or something
oh i'm sorry hang on a second oh that's
coming in clearer now
all right cool can you hear me now yes i
can
hey how's it going it's going well you
are cutting in and out it's very
unstable
oh okay um yeah uh sorry i'm using a
microphone to be dodgy
it's dodgy or stodgy dodgy
okay i got it okay fair yeah anyway i'm
just wondering like do you think
the what's go what's happening now here
and
also you know what's what's been
happening in the uk
uh politically do you think it's gonna
act as a wake-up call for all the
parties and craziness bs that's going on
because it's
absolute madness out there no no you're
saying you're saying like
will it be a wake-up call to these
nationalist right-wing parties that are
all over europe and
and in the us do you really think so
no i don't because it's so crazy and
it's so obvious
that's nonsense right uh you know from
the news to
all these crazy people on the internet i
think
at some point the wake up code is
overdue right i think you're right but i
think that this will embolden them and
they'll say look we got attention
and we got so close to doing something
even if they really didn't i'm worried
that they will be emboldened by this
well actually you're right but maybe it
depends on how they handle
all these uh all these supposedly
protesters who are actually white
terrorists right
yes you know and they should be called
by that name and
there should be repercussions for this
type of uh behavior and also all the
politicians need to be held accountable
right i mean ted cruz
you know absolutely how are you guys
doing these insiders the insiders that
it's the cat
stochastic terrorism is the term i've
used
yeah i haven't heard i mean i've watched
your previous stream and i've been
trying to grab like trying to see how
the u.s news uh
organizations would portray what
happened yeah it's a bit crazy because
you you don't hear
very early it was pretty clear it was a
political coup
as well as an attempt to you know aim
sort of
pseudo military coup at the same time
yes
but i don't i haven't heard that
explicitly
said as well as the use of the word you
know
terrorism right so if there's no
accountability then yeah you're right it
will continue
but if this is uh handled properly as it
should be
yeah you know democracy then you know
you could hope for a better
sort of tomorrow type thing right yeah
you you're completely justified in
everything you're saying i just think
it'll it'll go much the other way
right well we shall see brother we shall
see
so are you are you french and live in
london is that what it is
yeah for the moment i am you know i mean
i've been in london for ages
but with with what's going on here i
don't know if i'm going to stay for too
long to be honest yeah
well paris and london two of my favorite
cities in the world
yeah i don't think i'll go to paris
either really next
if i move i'll probably i'll probably
move to
somewhere like i don't know like in
portugal or something i just i just want
somewhere you know
with a better quality of life than
london or paris
interesting and portugal you think has a
better quality of life
out of the two yeah you make more money
in london
oh no no i'm saying sorry you say
portugal you have a better quality of
life
oh yeah absolutely yeah yeah yeah
interesting that's interesting yeah
by comparison to like london i mean you
buy the coast you buy the sea
there's more space there's less people
there's better food
you know as well kind of stuff right so
and and with the whole brexit thing
going on
nobody has a clue what's going to happen
so yeah i don't really know
where london is heading whilst you know
a city like
uh like like lisbon for example or even
rome
you know in italy is it's it's much more
uh i think that there's potential for
a better lifestyle over there of a much
more
you know better balanced lifestyle i
mean i'm in the center i'm in central
london
and effectively we've been locked down
for about a year
yeah right and it's like what's the
point of paying all that money even if
you make a lot of money
what's the point you know you're stuck
in the city you know so it's the same
thing like if you were in central
manhattan or whatever like right
yeah portuguese culture i loved i've
i've been to lisbon
sintra and porto and every
everyone has its unique charm and a
really interesting country
yeah and it's coming up right now
because we with the craziness that's
also happening in in london with brexit
a lot of european places uh are coming
up and lisbon is definitely one of them
yeah and
you know i i know a couple of people who
i've worked with in the past who moved
there
they told me great things about it so i
don't know we will see you
need to keep an open mind but very much
so yeah
all right my friend appreciate the call
yeah thank you yeah cheers have a good
one bye-bye
all right very good okay let's put a
pause on the calls for the time being
i'm told that the calls happening on
c-span or wacky so let's take a little
bit of a listen
no burning of police cars buildings
small businesses i don't promote what
happened but
obviously antifa terrorists are not
going to show up in trump shirts with
trump acts and trump flags
you know and not show
how they're representing they went in
there with a plan
a very precise plan and they
accomplished what they wanted
and what what proof do you have
of that oh it'll come out it'll come out
oh my god since it's being it's only a
couple hours
it will be it will be clearly coming out
yeah we've been waiting for two months
for the voter fraud proof
eight yes good evening
good evening um quite
quite a day uh turn of events in the
country uh definitely
a historic moment um however
uh these events in my opinion
are not surprising uh if we understand
the real conditions we live under at
this stage in capitalism
um you have we've got a trotskyist
what you had today was was a middle
class
middle class attempted adventurism these
aren't working class people
these people are not working um
they come in here and and and they
engage in this type of
adventurism and and we see the same from
the ultra left
and uh these type of actions are not
surprising and they will probably
continue because
the stage of capitalism we live under uh
precipitates this kind of alienation and
political violence
because we have so much alienation and
this is whack i'm glad people turn me on
to these calls
are uh more likely to occur now
it does shed light on the hypocrisy of
of the state doling out uh justice as we
see
um basically a group of he's gonna cut
it um
okay i'm gonna i'm gonna jump in because
i want to share this tweet we're a
couple minutes away here from
the senate reconvening uh ali uh
zaf zaslaff who reports for cnn sends
out
this video heavy law enforcement detail
escorting senators to the capitol the
joint session
is expected to resume at 8 pm eastern
time you can see it in there the
minority leader chuck schumer along with
other senators
being escorted into the senate
it's unclear though if they according to
the majority leader in the house denny
hoyer they're not going to go into a
joint session right away
they will resume their debate yeah
that's what's insane
the uh arizona objection the objection
to the arizona electoral college votes
they should drop it uh we will see what
happens again we should
immediately drop it where you can watch
the house floor proceedings
and over on c-span 2 you can watch
the senate daniel i'm going to try to
get you in in conyers georgia daniels
daniel yes ma'am good evening i am from
georgia and i just wanted to bring the
light
that there are a lot of people who
aren't holding their leaders
responsible for perpetuating this whole
entire
voter fraud scheme and one person i want
to call out
specifically is the queen of cupinon the
14th congressional district freshman
yes marjorie taylor green oh this guy's
great refused to wear a mask
while she's being sworn in and then
called nancy pelosi's
house as hypocrites and i find that very
hypocritical of her
um i've even spoke with her staff
in her own office today trying to get
her to stop
with her twitter account today and this
morning where she was in fighting
fight for trump this is an election
steal she's just as guilty as donald
trump
this guy's great she herself was
promoting
the fight for trump all morning long
so you know nobody's bringing up the gop
senators who were
bringing up all this stuff and nobody is
speaking out against her
and i want to be the first person in
georgia to say that we need to do
something
to have all of these leaders recalled
because they perpetuated the violence
that happened on the capitol today and
one thing that aggravates me about some
of these callers
is that they're not taking
responsibility
right for their crazy
nude nick belief that it's a stolen
election beautiful
okay daniel uh ali ziyati perfect
perfect phone call sent this out the
washington post editorial board
has called for the president's removal
we may actually see the removal of a
president
greta you've done a heck of a job and
i'm still here too
and what have you been thinking charles
as you've been watching today i'm an
expert witness on white-collar crimes so
i'm very observing
of things you do is c-span
the owner of the films that were taken
in statuary hall
say it again is c-span the owner of
today's films
taken in statuary hall i'm not sure
what's your point
okay i need them on those films i'll
tell you what i saw
and i'm observing as an expert oh my god
the party leading into statuary hall
when the crowd followed gently
was wearing a certain kind of shirt and
he was led in by a
police escort that police escort was a
capital police man
and that policeman led him she's about
to cut it
to the visitors gallery into
the into the uh house of representatives
i need that film you need that film
mr trump needs that film this is a
falsehood
and it was contrived and i believe i've
seen that man
let up by a specific patrol i'm going to
leave it there a lot of speculation in
town
columbus ohio this is the best
whoever told me to go to these calls
thank you believe it's karen
in columbus ohio okay yes go ahead you
know this is
this this is the first time i've ever
actually seen house clause 12b
rule one called which is an imminent
threat to the house
um imminent threat to the security of
the house i'm going to say something
here
the protesters became insurrectionist
the moment they breached the building
and they shouldn't go home peacefully
they should turn themselves into one of
the best things about these calls is how
nervous the hosts always are
about how quickly it can go bad they've
been misled just like all the other
people who
who are following this this guy who just
uses this position of power to uh
to do nothing but incite fear and
violence and hatred
and now insurrection okay
another report from a capitol hill
reporter senator mike braun
who objected to arizona's electoral
votes earlier in the day
on whether he will object again quote i
think today changed things drastically
whatever point you made before
that should survive yes that's what we
want as we should get this
if after all this they still object six
times causing 12 hours of debate then
then that would be even more of a
disaster subject to the call
and that means at any moment they could
gavel back in
their session where they left off was
debate over
the arizona electoral college votes
we'll wait and see if they continue with
that
if they do the debate will go on for
potentially another
hour and a half hour and 45 minutes and
then a vote will take place both in the
house and the senate
and then they would continue on with a
joint session
of uh saying what they should do is as
soon as they gavel back into debate
arizona say they have nothing else to
say and just move on
with the vice president presiding and
the speaker of the house next to him on
the diocese
in the house chamber that is how it's
supposed to work we're all waiting to
see
if that is how it'll happen tonight
uh well let's go to lisa in kentucky
lisa hi hello thank you
um i would just like to say that i
believe that the 25th amendment needs to
invoke
immediately we just have to harken back
to win president trump on the 2016
campaign trail so that he could actually
stand in the middle of fifth avenue and
shoot someone
and never lose a vote and at the time i
thought well
you know that's preposterous right but
as a as the cult of trumpism
has surprised into what
coming later today we can see more and
more how this attitude towards trumpism
instead of
a republican or democrat or democracy
has totally been eroded
and it's like anything that he says
that people are more than willing to buy
and and
act on apparently today and it's just a
dangerous dangerous precedent and i
began watching the feeds last night on
twitter
of what was happening on the ground
there in dc and i've continued watching
it today in just
other utter shock and how anyone
that is an american and a patriot and a
lover of this country can stand by
and allow this to happen i just pray for
all of us and i pray that everybody does
the right thing
when they reconvene in moments okay and
lisa
uh aaron chaff a political reporter
tweeting out that the senate is back
in the capital now with armed federal
guards
jonathan swann who reports for axios
tweeting out
striking part of a statement from
senator tom cotton who has been one of
president's most
loyal allies on the hill quote it's past
time for the president
they're turning on trump quit misleading
the american people
and repudiate mob violence michael in
littletown
littleton colorado michael
michael hey thank you for yeah hi thank
you for having me
um i just wanted to say that uh in my
observation i highly doubt that all of
these people that are out there doing
these atrocities
i i highly doubt they'd be doing this if
trump hadn't been out there repeating
these debunked lies
uh i think there'd be an obvious
transfer of power
uh and however as a result of the power
trump has over his admirers
we're now seeing these treasonous
actions of people
that are easily manipulated so we need
to move forward quickly with the removal
of the current president
and hold all of his enablers accountable
kathy plainville kansas kathy
go ahead can you hear me we can
yes i just want to say that i think
people better wake up
you know you think you're shocked and
you're surprised you need to talk to
people from venezuela
the exact same thing happened
the same thing happened in venezuela and
it's happening here
and when the communists take over you
will be shocked
i was wondering which way it was going
to go sahil kapoor of nbc tweeting out a
statement oh my god
barack obama history will rightly
remember today's violence at the capitol
incited
by a sitting president who has continued
to baselessly lie
about the outcome of a lawful election
as a moment of great dishonor
and shame for our nation
noah berman reporting that kamala harris
is now
arriving at the capitol and heading for
the floor
per staff again we're waiting for the
senate to reconvene
we were told it would happen at 8pm
eastern time it's six minutes
past the hour here on the east coast the
house is also
expected to reconvene tonight you can
watch it right here on c-span
and this the debate in the senate over
on c-span too
when they go into a joint session which
we expect them to do
you can watch that right here on c-span
uh byron where is pence speaking oh here
he is oh
thank you violence was quelled the
capital is secured
and the people's work continues
we condemn the violence that took place
here
in the strongest possible terms
we grieve the loss of life in these
hallowed halls
as well as the injuries suffered by
those who defended our capital today
wow and we will always be grateful
to the men and women who stayed at their
posts
to defend this historic place
to those who wreaked havoc in our
capital today
you did not win violence
never wins freedom wins
and this is still the people's house
and as we reconvene in this chamber
the world will again witness the
resilience
and strength of our democracy
for even in the wake of unprecedented
violence and vandalism
at this capitol the elected
representatives
of the people of the united states have
assembled again
on the very same day to support
and defend the constitution of the
united states
no not all of them so may god bless the
lost
the injured and the heroes forged on
this day
may god bless all who serve here
and those who protect this place
and may god bless the united states of
america
let's get back to work
wow
and by work they mean arguing that the
election shouldn't count
the majority leader ask unanimous
consent the majority leader and the
democratic leader be allowed to speak
and at the time not count against two
hours of debate in relation
to the objection raised maybe they're
gonna speak about canceling this let's
see
is there objection without objections so
ordered
i want to say to the american people
the united states senate will not be
intimidated
we will not be kept out of this chamber
by thugs mobs
or threats those are trumpist thugs he's
talking about
the lawlessness or intimidation
we are back at our post we will
discharge our duty under the
constitution
and for our nation and
we're going to do it tonight wow
this afternoon congress began the
process of honoring the will of the
american people
and counting the electoral college votes
we've fulfilled this solemn duty every
four years
for more than two centuries whether our
nation's been at war
or at peace under all manner of threats
and we're doing it today during an
ongoing ongoing armed rebellion and the
civil war
the clockwork of our democracy
has carried on the united states
and the united states congress have
faced down much greater threats
than the unhinged crowd we saw today
wow we've never been deterred before
and will be not deterred trump called
them special people
he calls them unhinged our democracy
they failed they failed
they failed to attempt to obstruct the
congress this failed insurrection
only underscores how crucial the task
before us
is for our republic
our nation was founded precisely so that
the free choice
of the american people is what shapes
our self-government and determines the
destiny
of our nation not fear
not force but the peaceful
expression of the popular will
now the adult thing to do would be to
cancel the two hours of debate about
arizona
his votes and to formalize their choice
of the next president
now we're going to finish exactly what
we started
we'll complete the process the right way
by the book we'll follow our presidents
our laws and our constitution
to the letter and we will
certify the winner
of the 2020 presidential election
wow criminal behavior will never
dominate the united states congress
this institution is resilient
our democratic republic is strong
the american people deserve
nothing less
i presume we'll hear from chuck schumer
democratic leader
mr president mr president
it is very very difficult to put into
words what has
transpired today i have never lived
through
or even imagined an experience like the
one
we have just witnessed in this capital
president franklin roosevelt set aside
december 7th
1941 as a day that will live
in infamy unfortunately
we can now add january 6th 2021
to that very short list of dates in
american history
that will live forever in infamy
this temple to democracy was desecrated
its windows smashed our offices
vandalized
the world saw americans elected
officials
hurriedly ushered out
because they were in harm's way
the house and senate floors were places
of shelter until the evacuation is was
ordered leaving rioters
to stalk these hallowed halls
lawmakers and our staffs average
citizens who love their country
serve it every day feared for their
lives
i understand that one woman was shot and
tragically lost her life
we mourn her and feel for her friends
and family these images
were projected to the world foreign
embassies cabled home
their capital their home capitals to
report the harrowing scenes at the very
heart
of our democracy this will be a stain on
our country
not so easily washed away the final
terrible indeli indelible legacy
of the 45th president of the united
states
undoubtedly our worst i want to be very
clear
those who perform these reprehensible
acts cannot be called protesters
no these were rioters and
insurrectionists
goons and thugs domestic
terrorists indeed they do not represent
america
they were a few thousand violent
extremists who tried to take over the
capitol building and attack our
democracy
they must and should be prosecuted to
the full extent of the law
let's hope hopefully by this
administration
if not by the next certainly by the next
they should be they should be provided
no
leniency i want to thank the many of the
capitol hill police and secret service
and local police who kept us safe today
and worked to clear the capitol and
return it to its rightful owners and its
rightful purpose
i want to thank the leaders democrat and
republican
house and senate it was speaker pelosi
leader mcconnell
leader mccarthy and myself who came
together and decided that these thugs
would not succeed
that we would finish the work of our
constitu that our constitution requires
us to complete
in the very legislative chambers of the
house and senate
that were desecrate yeah it it appears
this is a very good point from jupiter
saturn
the the riots have almost accelerated
the
finishing of this process were it not
for the riots interrupting things you
could have seen 12 to 14 hours of debate
it seems this is going to happen much
faster now voted conspiracy theories
that motivated these thugs
the president who exhorted them to come
to our nation's capital
egg them on
he hardly ever discourages violence
and more often encourages it this
president
bears a great deal of the blame
this mob was in good part president
trump's doing incited by his words
his lies this violence in good part
his responsibility his everlasting shame
today's events certainly
certainly would not have happened
without him without a doubt now january
6 will go down
as one of the darkest days in recent
american history
a final warning to our nation about the
consequences of a demagogic president
the people who enable him the captive
media that parrots his lies
and the people who follow him
as he attempts to push america to the
brink
of ruin as we reconvene tonight
let us remember in the end
all this mob has really accomplished is
to delay our work by a few hours
that's right we will resume our
responsibilities now and we will finish
our task tonight
the house and senate chambers will be
restored good as new
and ready for legislating in short order
the counting of the electoral votes is
our sacred duty
democracy's roots in this nation are
deep
they're strong and they will not be
undone
ever by a group of thugs
democracy will triumph as it has
for centuries so to my fellow americans
who were shocked and appalled by the
images on their televisions today
and who are worried about the future of
this country
let me speak to you directly the
divisions in our country clearly run
deep
but we are a resilient forward-looking
and optimistic people and we will begin
the hard work
of repairing this nation tonight because
here in america
we do hard things in america
we always overcome our challenges
heal the floor
now who has the balls i yield two
minutes to the senator from oklahoma
for the debate let's see senator from
oklahoma
the vice president you said things more
eloquently than how we say it in
oklahoma
in oklahoma we'd say something like why
in god's name
would someone think attacking law
enforcement and occupying the united
states capital
right but remember this was about
arizona are we going to debate arizona
or not if not let's just move on and
accept the vote
riders and thugs don't run the capital
we're the united states of america
we disagree on a lot of things and we
have a lot of spirited debate in this
room this guy's really creepy
but we talk it out and we honor each
other
even in our disagreement that person
that person that person is not my enemy
that's my fellow american
and while we disagree on things and
disagree strongly at times
do you get the feeling that this has
opened up the door
for everybody to just abandon trump not
necessarily super vocally and
aggressively but to just kind of
set him aside and do their own thing
sometimes a bad thing as many
republicans do but their own thing
forcing the national guard the secret
service
who stood in harm's way while we were
here debating
they were pushing back and i was
literally interrupted
mid-sentence speaking here because we
were all unaware of what was happening
right outside this room
because of their faithfulness and
because what they have done
and i want to thank you them thank them
ronald reagan once said peace is not the
absence of conflict
it is the ability to handle conflict by
peaceful means
the peaceful people in my state in
oklahoma want their questions answered
but they don't want this what happened
today
okay they want to do the right thing
and they also want to do it the right
way they went on
on the constitutional process but they
also want to have debate about election
security because they want to make sure
it's right
oh sounds like he's building up to two
hours of debate that still needs to be
resolved
transparency in government just doesn't
seem like a bad idea
obviously the commission that we have
asked for is not going to happen at this
point
beautiful understand that that's good
we're headed towards tonight
towards the certification of joe biden
to be the president of the united states
well said my friend we will work
together in this body
to be able to set a peaceful example it
sounds like they're abandoning the
challenge
i yield the floor wow democratic leader
senator from nevada senator cortez masto
senator from nevada
mr vice president
i know that this room is full of leaders
of both parties
who love this country and many believe
that for america to succeed
our politics must find common ground
and that has never been clearer
than today when armed rioters stormed
the u.s capitol
emboldened by president trump's false
and inflammatory rhetoric
about the 2020 elections i believe that
we in this chamber have a special duty
as
leaders to work together to lower the
temperature
of our politics and i hope that my
colleagues who have questioned the
legitimacy of this
election in arizona and all of these
other states
now see the dire and dangerous
consequences
of sowing doubt and uncertainty
i also know that as u.s senators we all
take solemnly the oath we swear
to support and defend the constitution
of the united states
against all enemies foreign and domestic
at this moment in history i can think of
nothing more patriotic
than renewing our faith in the charters
of freedom
that our founding fathers crafted for
our republic
starting with the fundamental so people
are asking so if they abandoned
what what happens um if they abandon
and republicans in the house abandon
they go back to the joint session
and then if there are no objections they
go through state by state do the
connecticut ballots look good
uh do the rhode island ballots look good
do the texas ballots look good that if
they are abandoning the plan to do two
hours of debate for each state that's
what's going to happen and it seems as
though the insurrectionist riots
are actually accelerating they are
actually accelerating the acceptance uh
as i just tweeted
for people who follow me on twitter um
senate republicans appear to be
abandoning what would have possibly been
12 hours of debate about voter fraud the
insurrectionist riots
appeared to have accelerated the
certification of joe biden's win
over donald trump to examine evidence of
voter fraud
before they certified their electoral
college votes
and our courts from district courts to
the united
states supreme court adjudicate legal
challenges and election disputes
all of those things happened after the
2020 election
state houses and courts across the
country took allegations of voter fraud
seriously
and followed the constitutional process
to hear challenges to this year's
elections
no state found evidence of any
widespread voter fraud and neither did
any court ask to review the state's
findings so trump sitting at the white
house
suspended from twitter watching this
happen
even faster than it would have had his
insurrectionist rioters not done their
rioting justice
robert brutnell all certified the
results of the election
on november 30th and we know we have
heard arizonans have been voting by mail
for almost 30 years
and governor ducey has expressed
confidence in the state's process
numerous times in november he said we do
elections well here in arizona
the system is strong and that's why i
have bragged on it so much
he further stated we have some of the
strongest election laws
in the country laws that prioritize
accountability
and clearly lay out our procedures for
conducting
canvassing and even contesting the
results
and they are right arizona has one of
the
most transparent election processes in
the country with built-in accountability
starting with eternal auditing
we have heard unfounded allegations that
voting machines in arizona and elsewhere
somehow changed vote tallies or somehow
improperly rejected ballots while
claiming
to accept them she should just rap these
allegations
all ignore the fact that arizona
counties
conducted ballot audits by hand
to double check the machine counts and
these audits found
no widespread fraud or irregularities
maricopa county the county where the
more than 60 percent
of the state population resides
conducted a post-election
hand count audit in the week after the
election
which showed perfect 100 accuracy
in the machine tabulations so why
would we need my colleagues to call for
a 10-day emergency audit
we don't by a legislative commission
when it's already been done by the state
of arizona
what happened to states rights i would
have preferred her to say
i appreciate the comments from mr
langford despite our disagreements we
are both on the same page about one
thing
the whatever committee that we are
demanding
is not going to happen at this point and
joe biden will be certified today
and with that i move that we vote on
this objection
maricopa's audit report stated
no discrepancies were found by the hand
count audit
boards seeking to find any reason to
contest these results
some of the state republicans then they
don't have to do two hours no for people
in conducting this audit by selecting
voting center location
when one thing i learned when i used to
work at circuit city
when the customer says yes to the
extended warranty
you don't keep selling it state court in
arizona found that the county
followed the properly issued guidance on
hand audit procedures
from the arizona secretary of state
and the court found that maricopa county
officials therefore
could not lawfully have performed the
hand count audit the way the plaintiffs
wanted it done if they had done so they
would have
exposed themselves to criminal
punishment
the senator's five minutes is expired
mr vice president i would close by just
saying
please my colleagues do not
disenfranchise
the voters of arizona value they move on
let's see
tonight thank you majority leader
mr president i yield up to five minutes
to the senator from utah senator lee
oh wow it looks like they're going to
keep going from utah
mr president at the time i prepared my
remarks
for today it seems like a lifetime ago
a lot's changed in the last few hours
and so
i'm going to deliver some of the same
remarks but it has a little bit of a
different feel
than it would have just a few hours ago
my thoughts and prayers go out
to the family members of those who have
been injured or killed today
my heartfelt gratitude goes out to the
capitol hill police who valiantly
defended our building
and our lives
well it's true that legitimate concerns
have been
raised with regard
to how some of the key battleground
states conducted their presidential
elections
this is not the end of the story
we each have to remember that we've
sworn an oath to uphold protect
and defend this document written
nearly two and a half centuries ago by
ways wise men
raised up by god to that very purpose
that document makes clear what our rule
is
and what it isn't it makes clear
who does what when it comes to deciding
presidential elections
you see because in our system of
government
presidents are not directly elected
they're chosen by presidential electors
and the constitution makes very clear
bad look
bad look that the states
shall appoint presidential electors can
somebody stop him
that their legislatures develop
then comes the 12th amendment it
explains what we're doing
here today in the capital explains that
the president of the senate the vice
president of the united states
shall open the ballots and the votes
shall then be counted it's those words
that confine
define and constrain every scrap of
authority we have in this process
our job is to open and then count
open then count that's it that's all
there is
now there are of course rare instances
instances in which
uh multiple slates of electors can be
submitted by the same state
oh no very often oh my god happened in
1960 it happened
in 1876 let's hope it doesn't ever
happen again and those rare moments
congress has to make a choice it has to
decide which of the electoral votes
will be counted and which will not that
did not happen here
thank heavens and let's hope that it
never does
now many of my colleagues have raised
objections
or had previously stated their intent to
raise objections with regard to these
um i i've spent an enormous time on this
issue over the last few weeks
i've met with lawyers on both sides of
the issue
i've met with lawyers representing the
trump what is he building to
i could find about the constitutional
provisions in question
and i've spent a lot of time on the
phone with legislators and
other leaders from the contested states
i didn't initially declare my position
because i didn't yet
have one i i wanted to get the facts
first and i wanted to understand what
was happening
i wanted to give the people
serving in government in the contested
states
the opportunity to do whatever they felt
they needed to do to make sure that
their election
was properly reflected
i spent an enormous amount of time
reaching out to state government
officials
in those states but in none of the
contested states no
not even one did
i discover any indication that there was
any chance that any state legislature or
secretary of state
or governor or lieutenant governor had
any intention
to alter the slate of electors that
being the case
our job is a very simple one indeed
this simply isn't how our federal system
is supposed to work
that is to say if you have concerns with
the way that an election
in the presidential race was handled in
your state
the appropriate response is to approach
your state legislatures
first and foremost these protests
uh from hearing from those who have
raised concerns
they should have been focused on their
state capitals not their nation's
capital because our role is narrow our
role
is defined our role is limited yes we
are the election judges
when it comes to members elected to our
own body and yes the house of
representatives
they're the judges of their own races
there
we also have the authority to prescribe
as a congress
rules governing the time place and
manner of elections for senators and
representatives
there is no corresponding authority with
respect to presidential elections
none whatsoever it doesn't exist our job
like that to convene to open the ballots
and to count them
that's it thank you mr president you
have the floor
yes democratic leader of colorado mr
bennett
senator from colorado thank you mr vice
president so they are going to keep
going so realistically this is going to
be the end of my time
um the this at least will go for some
time and then there are
47 more states to count and uh
it's going to go way later than than i'm
going to be staying up today
given how long a day it's been so i
really appreciate
everybody who joined me today we have
seen an incredible day
and we are going to have more tomorrow
we will be covering everything that
happened today
we will hopefully have a certification
by that point in time
um but that is going to do it for me and
i will probably see you back here
uh tomorrow thanks for everybody who was
with me today for what have been i think
today we may we creep we did seven hours
of content
including all of the other stuff uh
very much very very much appreciated
thanks to everybody we'll be back soon